thank you for attending this longer
presentation the plan is to most of it
setting up
my
okay yeah thanks everybody for coming so
um and listening to everybody else as
well so as UMES mentioned for the first
half of the LM program there will be a
parallel program which is a little bit
more classical but we're trying to be
non-classical that's why it's called
modern paradigms in generalization and
there are seven organizers so it's Peter
Bartlett um Daniel Sue polling low Tony
pasi Andre weski myself matus and Rich
ZL and then we have uh four workshops
and I'd also like to credit the workshop
organizers who have already been doing
quite a bit of work for those of you
that know how the Simon Institute
operates the workshops are kind of the
lifeblood of how a lot of these programs
work and the workshop organizers have to
do a lot so to the workshops are done by
me and Andre and then we have two
glorious other uh Workshop chairs Sor
kou from Columbia and Fanny Yang from
cage Zurich so a little bit about the
program and what what it means so what I
mean by generalization is the fact that
you have a machine learning algorithm
and you just run it on some data you
have literally lying around and then you
expect it to work on data you haven't
seen now I don't know why all of you
think this should
work okay but there's really no reason
it should and there's really no math
that says that it will and there's math
that says it won't but um again so
generalization
classically uh means machine learning
algorithms are given data and then you
expect them to work on future data and
in the classical setup there's a very
strong Paradigm which is data is drawn
IID and in the future you see IID data
from the same distribution now just to
show of hands how many people think this
ever
happens like
ever um what's the
example there's a un there's an infinite
number of things to consider I'm sure
that it happens
sometimes I
see um yeah so unfortunately if you open
a textbook you see examples like spam
filtering and spam filtering hilariously
is the absolute worst example because if
I were designing spam I would try to
optimize against what the person
designing algorithm is doing I'm
definitely not being IID so um if you if
you look at what generalization means
now I'll I'll just give two examples and
I'll say a third one verbally so you
know you buy a self-driving car you'd
like to take you home it was definitely
not trained on your home hopefully and
another example is uh let's talk about
llms right so what LMS do is you feed
text into them and you expecting to out
put something reasonable now let me tell
you how far this is from IID you can
look on the internet their entire sub
communities on the internet where all
they are doing is trying to find crazy
inputs to these
LMS okay they're explicitly trying to
break their training data okay I'm not
just talking about the jailbreaks I'm
talking about everything they do with
them so these Al these it's not just
that the paradigms are completely
different but the philosophies are
completely different if you open a
machine learning textbook you'll say
we're trying to say things like with
probability one minus Delta the algorthm
does something very close to the optimal
thing and just the funny thing is you
know that's actually a very strange
guarantee if you think about it so if
you drive over a bridge like Golden Gate
uh do you have a guarantee with probably
oneus Delta that the Golden Gate Bridge
is not going to
collapse anybody know what kind of
guarantee you do have on the Golden Gate
Bridge has anybody on on on the Golden
Gate Bridge and why do you trust it so
why should we trust LMS and what I'm
saying is that it's not just that the
techniques are going to have to change
but the goals are going to have to
change so there's a lot to do in this
program okay um so let me tell you a
little bit more more um so the high
level goals of this program are to
taxonomize Modern settings and make old
and new tools so I don't think all the
old tools have to be thrown in the trash
but I do think we need new tools and I
think all of us think that so we're
going to make a tonomy of kind of the
settings and and what tools we can use
and what tools we need to create so
extract tractable and hopeless questions
as a mathematician I'm very good at
producing questions I cannot answer and
um it's kind of a waste of time and so
we'd also to doce some tracable
questions we'd like to make our own
progress and Inspire other people to
make
progress I spent a long time making this
green sentence because we'd like to of
course mesh with the uh with the
UMES that's the it's this green line um
so I I view our program as sort of like
tangential and complimentary to the LM
program we will sort of study what
they're doing and and also do some of
our own things and another thing is very
important actually which is refocused
the ml Theory community so a lot of us
faced with how rapidly the settings have
changed are a little bit lost as to what
to do and the place where this is
actually the most difficult is for PhD
students so PhD students really in memo
the really don't know what to do and a
lot of top students are questioning what
they should do with their Futures and so
um this is a very sad situation and a
very scary situation and and we all view
part of the purpose of the program to
sort of refocus and determine you know
what we should be doing and it relates
to this question I said earlier about
the guarantees on the Golden Gate Bridge
by the way another puzzle about the
Golden Gate Bridge and the one minus
Delta guarantee on the Golden Gate
Bridge does anybody know the one time
that the Golden Gate Bridge that
actually started to Gran and the column
started to point towards each
other it happened once does anybody know
what caused
it yes yes so if I tried to prove a
theorem that says the probability one
minus Delta over the types of car
traffic you have in the Golden Gate
Bridge it will stay up
that guarantee would have told me
nothing about that incident which was
people walking across the bridge only
people it was an
anniversary so okay so another thing is
um the activities of the program so um
for those of you that aren't familiar
with the Simon
Institute uh there's the workshops which
you see externally but there's a lot of
nice stuff that happens between the
workshops and that's part of the the job
of the organizers to to to set those
things up and and what's always very
exciting is to have reading groups we
have weekly reading groups bring people
from from uh you know the area too from
Berkeley things like that we have four
workshops um broadly there's going to be
a boot camp there's going to be kind of
a a workshop focused on Theory practice
gaps one on distribution shift and one
on future settings the last one on
future settings we're quite excited
about we plan to have things like
philosophers showing up because what
does generalization actually mean like
do I generalize I not really
sure and um then there are the mini
workshops that UMES talked about where
uh the industry day is a great day to
talk about that because part of the
purpose of the mini Workshop is to have
industry participants come and visit and
uh UMES has done this for Quantum
programs and I was also one of the
organizers of the deep learning theory
program four years ago and we had uh
people from industry coming for that
actually prum who is here was one of the
people that was coming and and visiting
us um from Google at the time I think
I uh and then of course has has been
highlighted this might sound like a joke
but uh a very good way to get people to
do math together is to get them to do
things like cook
together and um this is my last slide I
just want to say a little bit
about why the Sim Institute is very
important and actually I think the Simon
Institute is more important for people
like me who actually come from outside
the Bay Area so the Simon Institute is a
just a wonderful way for us to meet lots
of people and um you know if you look at
our program we have people coming from
all over we have participants and and
chair a chair of one of the program uh
workshops coming from Europe and
um from the 2019 program The assim
Institute forms many long- lasting
collaborations so there was for instance
one research fellow in the program who
met her postto adviser and then now
she's my colleague in The kons Institute
and there are many such examples I can
point to many examples where some people
did not know each other at all they came
to the Simons Institute and they are
still active collaborators there are
many such from the 2019 program that I
did alone so this for me is the most
valuable thing about the Sim Institute
and for those of you unaware this is
quite rare so there are many conferences
and things where people just talk to
their friends they leave they met their
friends a lot but Sim Institute is very
good and uh this picture is a paper I
did with two friends who are close
friends now but I didn't know at the
time uh this is me and this is our uh
600 foot tall friend Peter Bartlett so
the pink is uh and yeah the other thing
about the Sim is whenever I come I
always feel like I get a good good uh
get the pulse of the entire Community
that's all I wanted to say thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you